chris is in new york city hey chris how
can we help
hey dave hey ken uh great to be on the
show thanks how can we help
yeah um uh real quick i just want to
give a shout out to my girlfriend maria
jose she told me to call
in um reason i'm calling is because i've
got a lot of friends who
are buying into cryptocurrency and you
know my investments are all
in mutual funds like you recommend
um and i'm hearing about you know
bitcoin dog
or dodge coin and all these other things
and i i just wanted your thoughts on how
to respond
when people try to pressure you to
invest into this stuff
and maybe even get your thoughts on
cryptocurrency in general
okay i wouldn't do it why
because i think it's still very
speculative we've already seen big highs
and big lows and i think it's still
rocky i do think that crypto is coming
and to stay
i think right now it's a lot of
speculation and until it gets adopted
and we start seeing businesses move that
way
i'd i'd stay on the sidelines and it's
not a part of our investment strategy at
ramsey solutions either
so there's that too which dave you're
far more versed in that than i am
it's had an incredible year yeah people
made a lot of money out this year
without a doubt no question about that
um
but they make a lot of money on cocaine
too
and they make a lot of money on uh you
know playing futures
and they make a lot of money at the
blackjack table and they make a lot of
money betting football
but these are not investment strategies
that's correct these are these are uh
things that you can jump into or jump
out of that are uber
unbelievable high risk and so the
problem is is that people don't perceive
the risk in bitcoin and it's there it's
it's it's a
it's not it's not fully adopted they
made a lot of money this year
made a lot of money in gold a few years
ago too and i'm telling people not to
buy gold
and all the gold bugs are going dave
ramsey's an idiot he doesn't understand
no dave ramsey completely understands
i've lost my butt in a bunch of high
risk investments over the years i quit
doing it
i don't like having to start over it's
too expensive
so if you want to start over play crap
that's high risk
if you don't want to start over do what
you're doing but you're not going to
convince friends who are making a bunch
of money that they're stupid
just let them be stupid and smile it's
okay